this story comes all the way from spain
tanks good news reports they've just
passed a law making pets an official
part of the family
spain is following france and portugal
on this and it means that in case
there's a separation divorce whatever
you want to call it uh you must consider
the welfare and the feelings of your pet
in deciding who gets custody not just of
the parents for example in one case in
madrid a couple got shared custody where
they alternated months with their dog
which has got to be confusing for the
dog but whatever in the u.s pets are
property by law so the person
registering the dog has legal ownership
but i will tell you i have friends who
didn't have children but had pets and
then went through a divorce and it was
really messy about how they did that how
they split that time up and they had to
come to some sort of agreement like a
shared custody yeah so my dog i have a
saluki which is a big dog it's like a
greyhound but it has fur oh
loki it's saluki they're fast they're
one of those that's what you did
yeah that's cj
for claudia jean
claudia my wife was a big west wing i
mean
west wing fan cj craig alice and johnny
for the west wing for real
i love it so my dog is amazing i got it
because she's fast and she can run with
me i like to run these days and so she
runs with me but she replaces my wife in
the bed
yeah that's a problem so
if i if she's not there she'll lay right
where tracy lays right if tracy is there
she'll lay on top of tracy's head
tracy's always like this dog is yours if
we're ever not together you're taking
this dog because she wants to replace me
anyway
all right next up it's the news you can
eat it's food
right
today we're talking about that
valentine's day classic that has been
refreshed
for 2022 food and wine reports this year
sweetheart candies will feature words of
encouragement classics like be mine and
kiss me which have been on the heart
since
1902
i had no idea that they were that old me
either they will be um coming up with
new phrases to mix in there um they'll
pump you up things like high five chin
up you got this
really someone's been through a pancake
right
i know i kind of want them to say like
stay six feet away from me
take a take a rapid test
i got proud of you i like proud of you
that's nice go time could mean
which is fantastic date night this might
be my favorite that's because this
typified my career don't quit
ah don't quit ever well
this one is my favorite it literally
says yuda best spelled y-o-d-a
this is my candy of 22. you the best
we'll be right back
[Applause]
[Music]